me puse mi chaleco antibalas
para los conductores de ambulancias de
jarquín se ha convertido en una rutina
salir bajo las bombas rusas para atender
a los heridos
está claro que es peligroso trabajar en
primera línea pero si no somos nosotros
quién lo hará
van dirección santifica un distrito en
el norte de jarquín bombardeado noche y
día por la artillería de vladimir putin
company
los habitantes están conmocionados
varios misiles acaban de impactar en la
zona
no llores no llores
uno de ellos destruyó este edificio
residencial todas las ventanas fueron
destrozadas por la explosión y la
policía teme un segundo asalto
despejen despejen despejen
al otro lado de la calle un centro
comercial fue golpeado cuarteles
escuelas u hospitales
la artillería rusa no se anda con
pequeñeces desde el 24 de febrero el
cuerpo de bomberos de jarquín trabaja
día y noche
doctor y lo peor es que a menudo
bombardean el mismo lugar varias veces
hemos tenido víctimas entre nuestras
filas
[Música]
este supermercado filial local del grupo
francés auchan ha sido parcialmente
dominado por el fuego
para evacuar a las víctimas se
necesitarán varias ambulancias no pasa
nada somos ucranianos
en este los residentes locales
resultaron heridos por fragmentos de
vidrio
rusos es realmente
criminales de guerra
la señora mayor sigue en estado de shock
cuando llega a la sala de urgencias
el resultado del ataque un muerto 14
heridos
de vuelta al lugar del atentado donde
los residentes están limpiando siguen
conmocionados pero estoicos
eso no me importa
svitlana profesora de ucraniano jubilada
nos invita a ver los daños
el misil explotó en el hueco de la
escalera pero la onda expansiva no se
detuvo ahí
438 eso era todo lo que tenía futuro
sí
[Música]
y es que ha sobrevivido estoy tan feliz
los platos se cayeron están todos rotos
esto era muy bonito
y al anochecer se reanudan los
bombardeos en el barrio